how can I keep my daughter 9 years old
away from these dangers from the
Internet only two things one you
actually don't let her spend time on it
which as you know is very hard cuz
everybody in her world will be on it two
and this is the most important the only
way I have a 13-year-old daughter and I
think about this a lot this is my number
one thing that I'm most passionate about
period in the end of world number one
way to protect the child is to build
their self-esteem when a child is not
insecure they don't succumb to Danger
make sure she's confident about who she
is her brains isn't overly reliant on
how she looks build her actual
self-esteem cuz you're not going to be
able to watch her every
minute